honestly exhausted and i don't feel well
i have a bit of fever
i did my test to cover it so i'm not i'm
coach-free
a day later maxime started finding
lesions on his body so i noticed that i
had now if you see it
having my thinker this pimple that like
strange that it appears in this part of
the
of the body
and also here
you can see
after speaking to his doctor maxine was
encouraged to go to his local hospital
in milan for tests
here he was placed in isolation
where health workers wearing ppe took
swabs of his lesions
i went to the internet and i saw all
these like like like
terrible pictures of the people with all
over the leisures you know and for me it
was really kind of scary because you
know like also i'm by myself and i don't
know with who i can share that
information as well you know so like i
felt a bit alone and i didn't know the
algorithm what i should do in this
situation
at first maxine wasn't sure whether to
go public with his story because he was
afraid of the stigma of having the virus
i
have a bad news i've got a monkey box
as you see it's over here
and over here and some other spots
he says it's important that people can
talk about monkey pox
it doesn't matter whether the person got
the disease it doesn't matter what the
reason of the disease you know it's
demanded the person is sick and he need
the help and if the person is going to
be by himself you know like and doesn't
know how to get help you know like what
is going to be worse for this
the world health organization says it's
deeply concerned by the number of cases
increasing across europe and this spike
in cases is putting pressure on sexual
health clinics here in the uk
who are often the first to come into
contact with cases like maxine's
my fear will be that sexual health
clinics in some parts of the country
will be unable to offer people um
appointments in time and that will
result in spread of infection not just
monkey pox but obviously things like
syphilis lgv and other things the world
health organization has stopped short of
declaring this monkey pox outbreak an
international public health emergency
but if cases continue to rise that might
have to change ashish joshi sky news